meantime joe biden and his brand new
running mate kamala harris unveiling
their most provocative move yet
calling for a nationwide mask mandate
take a look
today i want to talk about one thing
very
straightforward doesn't have anything to
do with democrats republicans or
independents
every single american should
be wearing a mask when they're outside
for the next three months at a minimum
every governor should mandate
every governor should mandate mandatory
mask wearing it's not about
your rights it's about your
responsibilities
that's what real leadership looks like
we just witnessed real leadership
and once again joe and kamala didn't
even bother to take questions from the
press
after the event dana perino i i think
at an event like this when you're going
to make a a big
policy splash that a lot of
constitutional scholars like myself have
major questions about
you'd think you'd be able to maybe open
it up for one maybe two questions
afterwards look they've got a strategy
from the campaign and they
are sticking to it and look it's working
for them for right now but as i've been
saying this week i don't think that is
sustainable
um and i think that a couple things on
this point
i believe it is politically smart for
them to
draw a stark contrast with president
trump on something
and if they believe that coronavirus is
the number one issue for the voters that
they are trying to reach
then you're pro that probably really
makes sense to them i saw a poll today
that said 82 percent of americans are
support such an idea
now however what would have been helpful
would have been
taking questions because well what do
you mean by that does that mean like
when you're
just sitting at home by yourself you got
to wear a mask no
i'm assuming that they mean in public
places etc
you know i don't feel it's my rights are
being trampled
if i wear a mask in a store i think
that's totally fine and the president
has said that would be a patriotic thing
to do
it took him a little while to get there
but he got there um i do think that is
excessive
to say that if i'm out on my own outside
walking and nobody is around me that i
have to wear a mask like that to me is
excessive
i think this showed something else and
the trump campaign might be able to
capitalize on it which is
this first policy announcement is
exactly how
they would govern from a federal
standpoint
as a nanny state type of thing where the
federal government's going to run
roughshod
they're telling the governors to do that
um but
you know that's just a suggestion but
what about if you tie money to it
that's one of the things that you can
try to do that's how you get states to
do
some things so again i think it's
politically smart
but i think it would have been better
for them to take some questions however
like they got they have this strategy
that seems to be working and i
think that they probably aren't taking
my advice to take more questions
yeah greg do you think dana's right
they're just trying to outflank the
president on an
issue like masks and they don't really
care about the
legality of it or the fact that you know
there's counties in maine that don't
even have one case
you know why should they be forced to
wear a mask when they're out on a
lobster boat
so i initially i heard this story topic
wrong i thought masked man date
so i have totally different talking
points
yeah you know maybe for that's uh maybe
for the gg
show yeah you're only at five whatever
you're into mask or no mask
date whatever you want so this is
leadership
this is leadership wear a mask i guess
uh he's gonna tell us to wash our hands
and then you know don't play spin the
bottle in the er
uh i find it hilarious that this is a
party that won't come down on rioters
looters or prosecute criminals or felons
who then reoffend but they're gonna
punish you if you don't wear a mask and
i'm saying that as someone who's very
pro mask i was wearing a mask before
the pandemic i'm wearing a mask right
now
but it is funny to dana's point so who's
the autocrat
now we've been told that trump was this
tyrant this autocrat
was just going to force everybody to do
what he wanted
and yet he said no you governors you do
what you want and uh
hopefully you'll do the right thing
we'll have 50 different experiments see
what happens
but now it's biden who's saying this has
to be mandated so it's
it's it's he the tyrant now is the media
gonna go after him
i doubt it but i might i do think this
might be a trap
that if you say like dana says this is
kind of excessive they're gonna say oh
you're anti-science and you want people
to die you're probably a racist in a
sexist too
yeah marie do you think this is a
tyrannical joe biden and kamala harris
going out there and demanding everybody
wear a mask wherever they are
well joe biden actually said each state
should do their
mandates on their own so he's actually
leaving it up to the states
so he's doing what that's for trump too
it's the same thing he's doing what
trump did so what's new
so what's new that everyone
everyone should wear a mask and the cdc
director today
said publicly that we are in store for
the worst
fall we have ever seen ahead of us
and he's been tweeting a lot about masks
this week there's a worldwide effort
this week to get more people to wear
masks
and look some states may have to mandate
this if people won't behave responsibly
on their own
a lot of states were trying to see if if
citizens would just do this on their own
out of the goodness of their heart out
of patriotism out of protecting their
fellow citizens
and unfortunately many people aren't so
if governors have to step
in and put in place some regulations
that when you go outside with a group
when you're in a store
whatever that gets people to behave
better
we need to do it we have a hundred and
sixty-five she must behave you little uh
irresponsible american children
marie why didn't they take questions why
didn't they take questions
i i don't know why they didn't take
questions but i guarantee you they will
at some point
at some point dana's point earlier this
is working for them joe biden is up in
every poll
double digits in many of them keep
thinking why mess with what's working
okay but they will listen i'm glad you
guys
think whatever you are doing is working
because there's going to be a rude
awakening
in november kennedy how do you see the
masks playing politically
okay it's not the idea that everyone
should be wearing a mask there are a lot
of things that we all should be doing
the question is what happens to you if
you're not wearing a mask
because here in new york city uh the
mayor encouraged people to
rat on fellow new yorkers and uh and you
were supposed to text and number and
take pictures of people
and de blasio said they were going to
send the police so what did people do
instead they sent him pornographic
images
so my worry is what will
the next wave be for
the real gestapo that comes in and spies
on people and lets the police know
because we already don't trust the
police so now we're supposed to trust
them with
mask enforcement to greg's point you
know we're going to talk about what's
not happening
in portland later in terms of people not
being charged
for rioting and violence but if you are
not wearing a mask
that is seen as the ultimate affront so
you will be punished there will be fines
if you don't pay the fines there will be
jail time
that is what is called force if that's
what real leadership
looks like if it's force i'm not into
that brand of leadership i thought this
was uh they wanted to empty the prisons
i didn't know they wanted to fill them
up with math squares dana
did you want to say something maybe this
is the democrats jobs plan they'll just
hire a bunch of
well they did say that they're going to
she did she did announce a 25 billion
plan in the biden plan for um contact
tracer so she called it a public health
corps
um that would start by the time i
calculated it by the time they did i
think
the vaccination that we would be
vaccinated but
anyway what i wanted to say is that at
this point in the campaign got 81 days
left
every single day you got to try to win
that news cycle right so three things
are the big story lines coming out of
today number one president trump with a
historic middle east deal
that was that's an amazing story right
should that be leading the news
absolutely but the president did
something else today on an interview
with fox news
fox business this morning he talked
about wanting to starve the
u.s postal service of funds because of
mail-in balloting
believe me that's going to be a story
but then now you have one other entity
and it's
it's now you have biden and harris
trying to figure out how can they
win the news cycle and they chose the
number one issue on americans minds
right today
they've probably focus grouped this
thing to death they know that the mask
thing is popular so
that's why when if you're the trump team
you gotta think like how could we win
this news cycle today
well we'll see how the nightly news
covers it i won't because i'll be
watching
special report but well that's nightly
news